-Michael Strahan.
That's how you do it. Come on.
-Ha ha!
-Ah, I love that you're here.
I'm so psyched.
We're gonna play Drinko.
This will be fun.
Drinko, do you want
to explain how the game works?
-Yes, Jimmy.
Welcome to Drinko.
In this game, you will
take turns climbing my stairs
and dropping two of your disks
into the Drinko board.
The disk will plink down
and land into these plastic cups
containing some
of my favorite beverages,
such as Frosé, jalapeño juice...
-What is Frosé?
-It's a frozen...frosé.
-What's dripping?
[ Laughter ]
Is something dripping?
-Something's dripping --
that's me.
-Oh, sorry, Drinko.
I apologize.
-Hey, that's cool, man.
We're all in this together.
And bone broth!
You must then make a cocktail
of your two chosen drinks.
-Uh-huh.
[ Audience groans ]
Okay. Okay. I get it.
Okay, good.
Of course,
Slayer's on the show tonight,
so we also have a skull
full of blood at the end.
There you go.
-Okay. I like that.
-That's fun, right?
Michael,
why don't you go first?
Why don't you climb up there
and make yourself a cocktail?
-Here we go.
Drinko.
-Ohh! Eee! Aah! Ohh! Eee!
-There we go.
All right.
You're gonna want to go...
I think --
No, that's suntan smoothie --
-I think
I want to do one right here.
No, if I go here,
it'll go that way.
-I-I don't know.
I would go on this side,
I think.
-I'm not listening to you.
You're my enemy.
-Whenever you're ready, Michael.
-Here we go, baby!
Come on!
Oh, no!
To the left!
-Jalapeño juice!
-Jalapeño juice.
-I don't like hot stuff, man.
-Jalapeño --
Jalapeño juice.
-All right.
-Now drop your second disk.
-What are we gonna mix it with?
Here we go.
Come on, baby!
-Hopefully, blood.
Get to the right!
Get in the blood!
-Prune jui--
[ Laughing ]
-Now it'll be hot
going in and out.
-Two of the things
I hate the most!
-Thank you.
Thank you, Drinko.
-Oh, my --
-Dude, prune juice.
[ Laughter ]
Prune juice and jalapeño juice.
-Dude, seriously.
Two of the things
I hate the most.
Do we -- We have a bucket
around here, right?
No, seriously,
I need a bucket, man.
-No, we do have a bucket.
-We got a bucket?
Thank you.
-Just in case.
No, I know.
Dude, this is making me laugh.
-I can't even
look at you pour it.
Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, don't look.
-Oh, boy.
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
Wait, wait.
Don't look, don't look.
-That's just one?
-No, yeah, don't look.
♪♪♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
They're doing it because they --
No, they're doing it 'cause --
They're doing it
'cause they like it.
-You know what?
You guys, the drum beat...
-No, no, no.
Don't look.
-Oh, that looks awful!
-Whoo!
-Just take a sip.
Just take a sip of it.
-If I'm in, baby,
I'm all the way in.
I don't go halfway.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my gosh!
You did it!
-Whoo!
-You are a man!
That is awesome!
Gosh, I almost got sick
just pouring that thing.
That was disgusting.
-James, it is your turn.
-What does it taste like?
-Ass!
[ Laughter ]
-Not that I know
what that tastes like!
You know what I mean.
[ Laughter ]
Whoo!
Go ahead, baby!
-Drinko.
-Aah! Unh! Eep!
-All right, here we go.
-Get ready, James.
Drop your disk.
-What do you want me to do?
-Drop your disk.
-Okay, good.
[ Light laughter ]
-Which cup will it land in?
-All right, I'm gonna say --
I want melted ice cream.
-Suntan smoothie.
-No, no.
I want melted ice cream.
That's good. Come on.
-Come on, baby.
-No, no, no, no.
No, no, no!
-Oh!
-Scope!
-What is it?
-Scope.
-The delightful mouthwash.
[ Audience groans ]
-Thank you, Drinko.
-It's green.
-Okay.
What goes with scope?
[ Laughter ]
I could pretend it's like
a mint julep or something.
-Blood.
-Blood, here we go.
♪♪♪♪
-Get to the right.
-Scope on Scope!
-Double Scope!
-You get Scope again?
-Yeah, double Scope.
What?
What does that mean?
-You may choose to do
another one, if you wish.
-No, I don't.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect.
I love it.
I can do Scope.
-Scope it out.
-But I never drank Scope.
Why are you giving me
two things?
-Because you got double Scope.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
I think you should
have to reuse my glass.
That would have
made it more interesting.
-No, no.
-Here you go.
-All right.
-This is not that bad.
I guess you don't
drink Scope, do you?
-You don't drink Scope.
This is bad.
Can I do that, like, legally?
That's way too much.
I'm not doing that.
-Is there a doctor here?
-Yeah, I can't --
-Doctor of good times.
-I'm gonna do half of that.
Oh, I mean, I just went all-in.
That's all I'm saying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And something's floating
in it, too.
-That's a fingernail.
-What is that?
-That's a Dorito from earlier.
-It looks like a piece
of somebody's tooth.
It does --
It looks like a piece of tooth.
-It does look like
some piece of tooth in there.
I can't do the whole thing.
-You can do this.
-Bottom's up!
-Do what you can.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Minty fresh.
[ Wah! Wah! ]
-Gosh...
-You okay?
-[ Exhales ]
-Ooh, it smells...
[ Laughter ]
Give me one more.
One more time.
-[ Exhales ]
-Whoo! Yeah.
-All right, it's time
for the final round.
Is there another round?
Okay.
Oh, this is gonna be a race.
We're both gonna climb
up there and drop a disk.
Whoever's disk lands first
is the winner.
The loser has to drink
a cocktail of both beverages.
-Are you okay?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I just drank, like,
a glass of Scope.
That's not good.
-You need help up the stairs?
-No, I'll be good.
I'm a little delirious
right now, but it's okay.
Here we go.
All right.
Oh, my God.
-Eep! Erp! Oop! Eep! Unh! Err!
Eee! Unh! Unh! Eee! Unh!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, please not be me.
I'm gonna lose it.
-So, whoever's last,
goes, right?
-Yeah, that's right.
-Okay, got to drink this.
-Get ready.
On the count of three.
One...
Michael.
...two...
-I'm ready.
-...three.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh!
-What is it?
-Prune juice!
-Prune juice?
-Prune juice.
-Again?!
[ Laughter ]
Poor dude. He can't do --
He can't do prune juice again.
-It did not land in the cup.
-No, I won.
-Yeah, I got to drink it.
I want to mix it with something.
I don't want it straight.
-Yeah, I know.
Yeah.
-Yeah, mix it with something.
Give me something else.
-Here we go.
I'm gonna mix it up.
All right, I'm gonna mix it up
since you dropped yours.
-See what kind
of friend you are.
-Come on, come on.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, come on.
Oh, man -- Oh, oh, no.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Scope!
-It's Scope!
-[ Laughing ]
-Hey, man,
I played a lot of games here.
This is the one I don't like.
-Thank you
for coming on the show.
You know we love you, man.
-Scope and prune juice?
-Dude, this is, like --
-No both friends
will be minty fresh.
-It's like a cleanse.
This is like a --
[ Laughter ]
This is like a cleanse.
That's all it is.
Don't look.
It's not good.
♪♪♪♪
This is like a juice cleanse.
-Whoo-hoo!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
That is exactly how to do it!
The one and only
Michael Strahan, everybody!